i have something fun for the whole
family
i think uh i have
brandon shop brennan schaub does a show
called the below the belt now for those
who don't know what below the belt is
well good for you
uh below the belt is a show where he
talks about fights
you know ufc fights because he's a
fighter so obviously he's
good at talking about him you know royce
shut the [ __ ] up he's good shut the [ __ ]
analysis i don't know i don't
you know sometimes i could put up with
the whole fake what's nice
i'm not fake he's good at talking right
now i'm not fake how am i fake
how am i fake you went to speech therapy
he's better at talking now
i [ __ ]
so uh there's some fun this is fun
little clips
i'm gonna back it up a bit there's
something we're gonna get to but just so
you know what he's talking about in this
clip so we could really
catch up he just watched the aaron
hernandez documentary before you hit
play too
i wanted i want to point something out
because people have been reposting the
old uh
the final episode that red band ever did
with joe rogan
like before he just oh okay before he
got into the fight
before they sent him off to a farm with
a nice loving family
and the game turned all the way up and
it dude
if if joe rogan if you even read the
comments a lot of people are like if
only joe rogan
spoke to brendan job this way you know
what i mean and kept him in check this
way i saw someone no one cares what you
think brian
yeah and just you smell you didn't kill
you're not you're not a killer on stage
stop it like all this [ __ ] and it's just
so funny to see him
he's had no problem kicking old brian
redman around but he will never be that
real with this dude
well uh well someone asked hey what
kicks is brett brennan wearing i don't
know man
we'll check it out so we're going to get
to the park once hopefully
just so we can um
just so we can lead up to what he's
talking to
he just watched the aaron hernandez
documentary on netflix
the mind of aaron hernandez i believe
what it's called and i have a feeling it
hit close to home
uh because of the cte thing but let's
just play a little bit
wilbur in boston the theater district
where i do uh stand up at
he goes back on trial for killing two
people there after a nightclub incident
so he's on that trial and you just like
he's talking to his agent he's talking
to his friends stuff you hear him on the
phone he's just like
i guess it got him to where he was at
you know as far as his confidence but
i mean i don't think he just doesn't
realize the the
consequences that he's d the
consequences
mike the problems what are consequences
you don't realize the consequences no no
no
no you said you [ __ ] said he's good
at speaking
are you yelling at me you said he was
gonna talk you said he was kind of
talking now
i don't think i ever said that prove it
pull the tape i don't believe you
he's a fighter so obviously he's talking
about
is that you know as far as his
confidence but
i mean i don't think he just doesn't
realize the the
consequences that he's dealing and that
wasn't even by the way at which one
point something got that's not even what
i want you to hear that i didn't even
know that was in there because
the one i watched here comes a little
late i also love the fact that he makes
it about him in the first
sentence yes again aaron hernandez who
by the way i used to do stand-up over in
that area
shut up you [ __ ] he murdered somebody
yeah the difference between brendan
schaub and hernandez is aaron hernandez
at least
has killed a couple times
yeah that's a good point
like the uphill battle he's like time
out when he gets out what are you
talking about homeboy
what they got life bro but um
so they he he gets found innocent of
that and they show him the courtroom and
he starts crying
and not guilty you don't get found
innocent you get found
not guilty which is there's actually a
difference there's a reason why
they say not guilty they say not guilty
yeah and you figure out why he's cr i
was like right
he already has life why is he crying
over this because you realize what's
going on
it's heartbreaking you realize it's gone
because that's he's crying because a he
won so he's kind of
vindicated with that b it's the last
time he's gonna see his
wife and his uh baby girl because he
knew he's gonna kill himself
brandon shop tells the story the way a
child tells you a story
you know yeah like a nephew or niece
so then so then so then when i was
watching so then hey are you listening
hey uncle merch are you listening
very limited yeah uh point of reference
for the world you know just a very
simplistic and
childlike view well you're gonna love
what's coming up oh yes sam
yep it's super heartbreaking man super
heartbreaking
you know what's more heartbreaking that
he killed three people
yeah that seems to be more heartbreaking
it seems to be uh
kind of heartbreaking that you know
what's heartbreaking noise uh
that he left his child without a father
that's he would rather do hood rat [ __ ]
yeah that's heartbreak yeah it's a it is
a it's a good documentary and then you
find out
they right they want to look into his
brain and uh
he has some of the worst ct you've ever
heard of
what's ct well somebody with cte would
call it ct
oh okay uh and they've that's first off
he's only number one because we haven't
examined yours yet brendan
we're not there yet bud ever
ever ever how [ __ ] scary is that man
yeah brendan schaab's brain
probably looks like my liver
[Laughter]
so scary super super scary
because he was hey he was you know not
that old
and if he has that not that old
he was 27 when he died that's not very
young that's
thank you that's not not that old that's
extremely young
that is that is a ridiculously young age
because he a who you know not that old
and if he has that i mean you gotta
figure it there's
there's a bunch of guys out there you
know why that guy laughed
obviously because brendan schaab is
talking and he's a [ __ ]
killer comedian dude you see now you're
doing it so
you know you know what he laughed he
laughed because he thought brendan was
going to throw himself under the bus
which
i would have had more respect if he did
if he goes you know who knows what i
have man
but instead he goes who knows other
people out there what they might have
we don't know about a bunch of guys yeah
they said it's one of the worst cases
they've ever seen
we already said that terrible man yeah
man it's really
terrible terrible they're saying it's
like literally one of the worst cases
they've ever seen yeah we know okay
is theo vaughn available
that's really sad yeah it's it's you
what you watch it's heavy you're just
like really really
dude it's [ __ ] crazy like a
documentary about somebody getting
murdered is heavy no [ __ ] brendan
it's like it's really nuts that you know
such a talented guy
and he goes out he just murders these
guys
and he had like one of the worst cases
that they'd ever seen oh my god stop
i just can't help it with him you view
him a little different
you know yeah you view him a little
different
but uh why is this a view with a
baltimore accent
because he's [ __ ] like what
good man it's definitely worth the watch
another thing on netflix would be the
the series chairs wait what
wait no what wait what
no no no no no no no no no no what is
now i want to give credit here
because i don't want people who still i
found this clip
because it came up on my uh on the f i'm
in the fighter and the kid read it
and because you hate yourself they're
really funny no they actually do hate so
all i saw like it just you know
sometimes you get email when you're
ready just get emails like this is a hot
thread very annoying so somebody
posted a picture
of lawn chairs and then in the cheers
text chairs and i was like what is this
and then i find okay so what he's
referring to when i figure this it took
me a while
i figured it out there's a documentary
called cheer
c-h-e-e-r which is about cheerleaders on
netflix
but he thinks it's cheers like the you
know ted danson show
but he called it but uh it's good man
it's definitely worth a watch another
thing on netflix would be the
the series chairs so let me get this
straight
you took the word cheer
you changed it to ch not only did he
change it to
chair but he pluralized it
this man is profoundly stupid
profoundly stupid hey royce did you know
that they say that aaron hernandez was
one of the worst cases they'd ever seen
[ __ ] kill you if you bring that up
second worse brendan and you're
instead of killing people you're
murdering the english language
like i don't understand it before a
fight to practice would brendan stick
his head inside a [ __ ]
uh one of those paint can shakers this
is literally
what happened to his brain is what
happens to was what happens to a bottle
of hand sanitizer when thomas murphy
gets a hold of it seriously
dude the guy who the guy in casino whose
head they put in advice was able to
speak
more eloquently after his eyeball popped
out
but uh it's good man it's definitely
worth the watch
another thing on netflix would be the
the series chairs
cheers cheers we're the cheerleaders
here
yeah with cheerleaders now now he knows
that the show is about cheerleaders
right so he's able to say cheerleaders
so wouldn't like wouldn't you
make the connection that you mean to say
cheer
because he could say cheerleader so he
could say the word right he
i've said this before about brendan job
to he reminds me of
me when i've just woken up like just
immediately
just woke up and and one of the worst
things you could ever do to me is start
hitting me with
questions about things when i've spoken
up you can't even do it when he's
[ __ ] been awake for hours that's fair
but this this is that reminds me when
you start asking god i'm like which
i asked the chairs it's good it's a good
thing
it's chairs oh cheerleading thing you
had chairs
i think we talked about this last time
the
director of this who also did last
chance u was like
cheerleading is harder than football
chill i like the headlines so he gets
ratings but chill you know what i'm
saying they do flips everything's all
good
um it's it's good
it's really good it's weird it's like
this little podunk like
like [ __ ] juco college in texas
i want to point out that this show is
below the belt it's his fight recap show
and i know it's a little fight it was
conor versus cowboy so i know it wasn't
like a big you know thing
but maybe you think he's gonna get to
talking about the fight wasn't there
like
i don't know six other fights on that
card mike
mike have you not seen have you not seen
the great the
great great sitcom on netflix frazier
yeah they said it's the worst case
they've ever seen
there was like six other fights on that
card royce
how long is this hour and 18 minutes i'm
not playing all of it are you kidding me
but i just wanted i really wanted you to
you i mean i'm pretty sure you and i
could do
a more extensive i don't i didn't even
watch that fight and we could probably i
could probably [ __ ]
for one hour have you seen chairs
i'm a big fan of it i thought it was
gonna be a documentary about carpentry
and he's also later on this episode i
don't have the time stamp but
do you know you see the hat he's wearing
49ers right
he gets asked hey who you rooting for in
the super bowl you know what he says
i don't know man
put this for san francisco's in in the
super bowl
i don't know man bro i don't know man
hey brandon brendan dude you gotta
somebody's calling frasier yeah you
don't watch fairs
this and they're like the best they're
just the best they have the
nick saban of fema uh somebody said okay
i'm gonna read this this is great i
think this is worth reading i think
uh why do you two hate shops so much
what did he ever do to you i understand
he's annoying af which mike stands for
as [ __ ]
uh you clearly jealous due to his
success lifestyle
millionaire youth slobs are failures
obese
and bald look the last thing is fair the
last thing is fair i'm not bald i'm just
lazy i am though i am he's bald i'm not
bold but no that and obese is fair
look this is fine this is fine you're
right we are these things
that's perfectly fine you can insult us
if you want no let him insult it that's
perfectly fine
but why do we hate on brennan so much
did you just hear him say chairs
if it wasn't for the reason brennan's
easy to make fun of besides being stupid
we're not picking on
we're not picking on some cte guy that's
living in a [ __ ] homeless shelter you
know what i mean but i would if i found
one
[ __ ] and i would give that son of a
[ __ ] a beat i would [ __ ] [ __ ] up
this guy
if you think there's plenty of other
people to be jealous of right like
there's
there's plenty of other people that are
successful there's plenty of other
people that have great lifestyles
there's plenty of people that make a
bunch of money that you could go oh you
know what i'm kind of jealous of that
you know like i [ __ ] made like here's
here's a going for you
if you were to tell me someone like him
and you jealous i'm jealous of a dave
chappelle
there you go that's a good one for many
reasons not just for the money not just
for the lifestyle
i'm jealous of somebody who like dave
chappelle who had the balls
to turn down 50 million dollars from
comedy central because he couldn't do it
his way
and then he came back and he goes in 12
years he was off tv
i'm not jealous of dave chappelle and
then he came back and then i'm like man
you know what good for him not many
people could do that
who are you jealous of i'm not jealous
of dave chappelle who are you jealous of
he's black
no not that part i'm just kidding i
meant lifestyle
no no i get it like i don't know man um
i'm i'm really trying to think of
somebody that i'm like wish i had who's
no i don't mean like that but you know
to be like
that's somebody i'm jealous it's the
wrong word respect envious
uh i don't know um
i don't know i mean like louis ck's got
it pretty good there's a good one
that's part of the reason i respect um
no i mean look at the end of the day
his job is to speak
and he's bad does his job poorly and our
show
covers people who do things poorly and
we make fun of them for it
you know mike they say it's the worst
case they've ever seen
[Laughter]
see what it means funny because he's a
dummy but when people
people try to twist it into this thing
sometimes where
like they assign uh they project or they
assign motivations to you that you don't
have
like to say that i hate brendan schaub
implies that when the mics turn off that
i'm just like oh
my [ __ ] oh i hate that brand i don't
even think about it when the mics are
off but like we goof on people on the
shows of course we're like
can you believe this [ __ ] this
mushmouth idiot can't even say
cte the thing he has and to me it's
funny
because of what mike said earlier i mean
talking about brennan's he may look
let's be honest here he makes it easy
right like he makes it easy
we're not exactly you know doing doing
backflips
trying to figure out how to make fun of
him you know look at him he's a dumb guy
like he's not a smart guy right
he has a 1.8 he if you were to tell if
you were to take his name out of it
right
and you were to go hey there is comedian
x
he has a one point eight rated f uh net
uh showtime special on
imdb it's doing so bad that he's giving
away free cbd so people rate it higher
and then you were to go but also joe
rogan's helping him be like
wait a second why why would joe rogan
help him like
this guys the problem is is that
we all agree that if it wasn't for the
rogan push
he wouldn't be doing this
this is manufactured this is a
you have to like him because he's part
of and you know rogan doesn't even call
himself death squad anymore because he's
embarrassed of it of course
but this is all part of that little
death squad thing this whole little
little you know sycophantic rogan thing
and
rogan is someone who prides himself on
being i'm being honest right we talked
about the red
band thing when he was like shut up you
[ __ ] you stupid don't care you [ __ ]
and stuff like that he is not honest
with him and i don't want anyone to
point out like oh yeah there's that time
he told him that you'd be surprised
about fighting
but he softened the blow by saying you
should do stand-up
there are comedians there are [ __ ]
hilarious comedians right
that have been doing this for decades
that does in my opinion deserve a
showtime special right
and aren't getting one but somebody like
brandon schaub who is not a funny guy
he cut the line yeah i get that a lot
you know what you're talking about being
jealous
here's the truth of the matter is you
[ __ ] people that defend brendan
sharma go you're just jealous of his
lifestyle
you're the ones envy you want to be him
you want to be the cool jock in school
that was banging the broads and crushing
puss
you think this is cool you think a guy
wearing tight jeans and
and gold sneakers is cool that honestly
says more about you than it does about
us
we're goofing on him sure but you want
to be this guy you are jealous of his
lifestyle you want to be the millionaire
you want to be the fighter when you walk
into a bar and you can pull up at the
comedy cellar and park your porsche up
front
when comics have been doing for 20 years
aren't allowed
you know you want to be friends with
paulie sure i guess yeah
but you want that i don't want that i
don't i don't want to be this guy this
is embarrassing
like his own people that are fans of his
show goof on him
because he's not good at what he does
guys like brendan shaw are getting
opportunities they don't deserve
so yeah we're going to goof on the guy
yeah ducks doug stant hopes
doug stanhope is doing is doing shows in
like in a podunk town in utah
every weekend and brendan shobs doing a
[ __ ] showtime special does that sound
like right to you
does that sound normal to you it doesn't
say what you look as a perfect example
let's talk about patrice you want to
talk about somebody who earned it
patrice o'neill's first comedy special
was probably one of the best ever like
he [ __ ] cried it was comic was
was was it on comedy central was that
where his elephant in the room was
i think so yeah he [ __ ] crushed it
brennan goes to show you that you would
have more respect for him if he was
doing the road for a while and like
really put his dues in but he just came
under the [ __ ] scene
and then he gets a showtime special
while at the same time
talking brian callan out of doing one
out of doing a netflix special
so he could hawk more fighter in the
kid's shirts
so yeah man brendan's a [ __ ] dummy
he's gonna be made fun of and you know
what he needs more speech therapy and
he's stupid and he has three shows
you think it's jealousy no what it is is
it's amazement
this shows you everything that we talk
about if you're well connected enough
it doesn't really matter if you're funny
or if you're talented if you know the
right people
you're gonna get one of these shows
you're gonna get a fight analysis from
somebody who who was in the ufc who
can't even do a fight announcement
yeah this is my fight analysis for the
ufc fight you guys seen chairs
yeah jim norton who's never fought a day
in his life does better fight analysis
than him you know and his is terrible
too yeah
louis j gomez with bisping do better
fight analysis
than this guy does you want to hear
every one of jim norton's fight analysis
ever
bro that guy is a problem yeah that dude
is a problem yeah
and then he'll talk about he suck his
dick out of respect and stuff yeah we
know i know all the bits
i know all the bits i know all the bits
jimmy can you do a can you do a hold on
me while you're in the studio
we know we know jimmy the only way you
could come now ah
but it's easy to make fun of him because
he makes it easy this isn't
we're not stretching with this guy you
know he called the chairs
and maybe you give him leeway and you
got we know we don't crush enough puss
and we're fat and we're losers
and that's what really mattered being a
millionaire and having a cool leather
jacket
you know so cringe right it's these
people think that being cool is the bad
guy in an 80s teen movie like that's
what they think
cool is sorry that we're not [ __ ]
sweeping the leg in karate kid all right
petey has a good point in the chat merch
is mad because when brendan schaub shows
up for shows he gets a breakfast
sandwich
hey i got to finish the breakfast
sandwich it was already ordered
i got to keep the sandwich or just got
screamed at about it
that's fair yeah i still got the
sandwich bro
they weren't just gonna throw it out
so look and by the way he shouldn't be
crushing any puss isn't he married
i don't know i don't know enough about
him back together no but again i'm
obsessed with brandon schaub and i hate
him
don't even know he's married don't get
right right sometimes the video pops up
we goof on him when we move on
somebody goes you guys wish you could
put shoes on the table
if somebody put shoes on the table
they're getting yelled at somebody says
i prefer the bad guys in movies based in
the 40s
okay well hey at least they were well
dressed all right at least
no no no no no no those weren't the bet
never mind
those weren't the bad guys were going to
say that no i wasn't going to say that
at all
i was going to say you know it's
actually they said it was i was going to
make that goddamn
cte they'd ever seen i was about to go
you have to forgive mike cause they do
say
uh maxie max and cheese if making fun of
someone
uh making fun of someone mean you're
jealous of them
then they i feel really bad for the
people making fun of youtube yeah
seriously jersey [ __ ] i'll bet you
absolutely
why would you be jealous of us [ __ ]
suck
uh and it is funny it's it's it's the
fact that he
has been embraced because he's friends
with joe rogan that's all you need to
have a career now is be friends with joe
rogan
that's it that's the only reason mckay
does not have a career yeah
the only reason michaela peterson is is
selling her [ __ ]
[ __ ] sonny's barbecue diet
is because her [ __ ] dad is peterson
and he's friends with rogan and it's the
only reason
with my diet you can eat eight out of
the ten available foods at golden corral
exactly thanks